we will be coming out of break in just a
moment
right now we are gathering people who
have been
is this working okay we're coming out a
break this wasn't a recess
it was a break so
representative edwards is up on his part
of the discussion
on the health and human services budget
uh thank you mr chair i
i i think we just followed the 1940s
movie paradigm of the cliffhanger
uh when we last left our intrepid hero
uh senator daniels uh uh i was curious
um about these uh mobile crisis response
teams i'm
i'm looking at line 63 in between line
63 and 64 on the system of care
over the biennium the senate added
approximately 5.3 million 5.4 million
and the mobile crisis response team is
is mentioned as part of the
justification in the footnote
uh i'm just i'm just curious
if the senate received
good information about the status
of the state's efforts to stand up these
mobile response teams because
it seems like whenever there's a need
for money
the somebody uses the magic words mobile
response team and money is provided so i
was just curious
senator thank you uh i believe that the
the department uh
you know has been seeking these for a
while and sometimes they've been funded
sometimes
they haven't we looked at it as is part
of our plan
for starting to address what the root
cause of things are
we we understand that areas like mental
health are growing at such a rate
and we're pouring more and more money
into it and we've told the department
it's not sustainable
we need to go back we need to find ways
that we can treat people before they get
into the system before they get into the
hospitals
mobile crisis units were part of that
plan so that's why we put it in there
the expectation is this will be part of
what we're monitoring
yeah and it would be uh it wouldn't be
logical for us not to monitor
you know if we're going to put that much
money into trying to prevent
uh a system from from continuing to grow
we want to make sure that it's working
if it's not working
then we will change to something else in
the future thank you senator i think i
think we agree on
on the identifying the problem and
hoping that this is as part of the
so i would like to move on to
[Music]
line one zero eight one zero eight
is surrounded by a bunch of lines where
there's
been some accounting changes without
real policy changes
and on 108 we see 1.6 million dollars a
year
being taken out of the state's budget
this is money that
was was going directly to
planned parenthood of northern new
england and
and i think maybe some other abortion
providers
this is coming out of the budget that
3.2 million dollars
we won't see any more but that's still
money as i understand it that is
still going to uh planned parenthood is
that your understanding sir
if i recall correctly and uh that uh
this money was removed because of the
expectation that federal funds
would basically supplant them ah so so
it is going to be federal money going
yeah i'll defer to lba
sure yup sure so
this 1.6 million was budgeted in error
these are federal funds that aren't
available at the moment because of
changes to title 10 funding a couple of
years ago but there's an expectation
that they will become available
shortly but even if they are made
available they wouldn't go through the
state they would go directly to family
planning centers and so
there's no need to budget them and they
shouldn't have been budgeted originally
so the department requested that they
become out that they come out
so that's what you see here all right
thank you for that
um while we're on that line item um
uh the house and the senate
have agreed that an fy22
will put 812 000
into the family planning program and
general funds
that's not reflected in any paper that
we have
and that was right what the governor had
recommended
in addition to that what the house did
is we put another supplemental 50
000 on that general funds line
in order to incentivize additional
competition for these family planning
contracts
and as as i understand the senate's uh
proposal
in the section 34 that we had done where
we
were intentionally trying to incentivize
new vendors that i as i understand the
senate version
it it doesn't have that and now hb2
needs hb1
well in their hp 2 but it affects hp1
so so so in anticipation of that
conversation
what i what i'd like to do is go ahead
and from
hb1 take the 50 000
supplemental money and just pull it out
of hb1
because that would be redundant money or
unnecessary money
if we were to seed to the senate's
version
of hb2 so so i would like to
i would if there's any discussion on
this
we can discuss it but i would like to
move that
in hb 1
we remove the 50 000 supplement
that was added to the state's family
program money
uh in order to clean up hb1
and get it ready for an hb2 discussion
next week
what accounting union is that
we're referring to uh row 108
so you can reference it there there's a
family program that's federal money
the line we're talking about is federal
money but the program is there
uh mr ripple can tell you the program
number sure so the accounting unit is
and in your compare report it's online
on pages 12 24 and 12
25. so what representative edwards is
referring to was 50 000
that the house added uh that the senate
kept along with the corresponding
footnotes saying that 50 000 shall be
used for the purpose of providing
incentive funds to first-time contract
awardees so i think what you're
suggesting representative edwards is
that both the fifty thousand dollars and
the footnote would come out of house
bill one
um yes mr ripple that's exactly what i'm
trying to
the motion i'm attempting to move here
okay
representative okay if i'm understanding
correctly
that doesn't show up here because it's
the same for both the house and the
senate
what's being asked is that we
find whatever line item that is
and reduce it by the 50 000.
along with the footnote yeah yeah okay
55.30 so that's that's the motion that
we
if we well
it's account 5530 which is on pages 12
24 and 12 25 in your compare report
okay if you want to look it up
representative over
mr perhaps mr ripple can respond to this
and i see that
both the house and the senate have
neither one of them seems to refer to
the use of any general funds so are we
talking entirely
federal funds and have we received those
federal funds
this 50 000 is a general fund
and so if you go to the previous page uh
that shows you the class lines for 55.30
you'll see on line 103 uh
that 50 000 that the senate left in
that was the 50 000 that the house added
so when we take this out the agreement
is to put it into hb2
if if we add it back it'll be in hb2 and
that's for
monday's discussion or tuesdays does
everybody understand the motion to
remove
from hb1 do we actually have an
amendment
you don't have a formal amendment but i
think you could direct us to make that
change
okay thoughts from the senate
senate so just for our understanding
thank you mr chair uh
your intention is to still provide this
funding
i would like to uh have the
senate agree with my position on monday
or tuesday relative to
enforcing the financial and physical
separation of family planning from
the reproductive health facilities but
on the thought that the senate may not
support that
we won't need this 50 000 in that
scenario
because this 50 000 is entirely intended
to incentivize new vendors to replace
the reproductive health facilities that
already have
the contracts so this was this fifty
thousand is incentive money
for new vendors and if we were to agree
with the senate
next week this 50 000
would would not be needed and so
therefore i'm just trying to clean up
the books
while we're while we're on hb1 and get
okay mr chair a question for the lba
do we need to make that change in hb1 or
could there be an hb2 amendment that
depending on what the committee of
conference on hb2 decides
directs the spending yeah it's up to the
committee you can address it here
and reduce that class line or you could
reduce it in an amendment to house bill
reducing this class line by 50 000 so
it's up to the community
both would be appropriate and
i'm addressing it now because i'm at the
table now monday i'm an alternate so
i'm not sure where i'll be on monday
well if you left it here the way it is
then the money would be there to
incentivize
i don't know what will happen on monday
tuesday and wednesday
so if i'm reading the chairman right i
should withdraw this motion
yes mr mr chairman i withdraw this
motion
thank you okay and so with that
i think i am prepared to say that
um on the senate versus house uh
form that we've been using i i move that
we accede
to the senate's position from lines 49
all the way through the end of it on
146. second
okay motion in a second for the house
members to exceed
on those aforementioned line numbers 48
through
146.
any further discussion senator rosenwald
thank you
reluctantly not that reluctantly
i'm not going to be able to support this
motion
not only because i think the additional
1.2
million dollars is needed for the title
uh program um they're all over the state
planned parenthood is one of them but so
is coast family
coast health center so is
amiskeg health and there are there are a
number of them
but i'm also concerned about the three
million dollar decrease
in the state loan repayment program i
know the senate
added money from the house position
but we have a really
critical shortage of health care
workforce
and i'm concerned about that too
so senator what line do you refer to i'm
looking at line
51 and i have to say that senator
hennessey
worked this unbelievably but
we were not able to get back the entire
level funding of the current biennium
while the problem continues to be
exacerbated
thank you thank you further discussion
senator hennessey thank you um outside
of the budget process
i am hopeful that the monies that are
coming into state from the
the federal monies coming into the state
will address
the the needs of a lot of our health
care providers
that have that we have seen um
drastically increase because of the
covet pandemic and i'm hopeful that
those funds will be used for
the student loan repayment program or
slurp which we
love to refer to it as and that we will
see
a significant increase in funding for
our health care professionals and their
student loan repayment
thank you and follow up follow up and as
far as the federal funds go i
i am upset that the federal government
has not decided to
provide the funding to our uh family
planning services that they
they should have increased by now and
and and are very able to increase
um and and the supplant
by supplanting these funds with general
funds it's it's calling on states to do
something that i don't think we
we should have to do so i would i would
recommend reaching out to your federal
delegation to
tell them to do their job on this and
and get these fundings to
our our needed services especially the
ones that
um that we can agree on definitely need
these
this funding senator rosenwald
thank you i believe that the uh
current federal administration is
working to get that money out
directly to the states but it will take
probably until next winter or spring
before the providers who have been
ineligible to participate in
title 10 are able to re-qualify
again so i think in the meantime
we're reducing
access to important health care for
further discussion seeing none the
motion is for the house to exceed
to the senate position on the
stated correctly no see no further
discussion house members all in favor of
hands down senate members in favor of
the motion
it's two to one motion passes
the next thing we have is i guess
education
and that will go to representative
umberger
you mr chairman i uh would move to a
seed to the
senate position second okay
house moves to exceed to the senate
position on the department of education
changes further discussion
i certainly have no problem with these
all right i guess i should say in hb1
senator rosenwald thank you um i'm
concerned about
the level of k-12 education going out to
our cities and towns so i will not be
further discussion seeing none
uh representative umberger uh thank you
that's
in the regular budget and not in here is
you said you were concerned about the
amount of money that was going
out to our cities and towns for adequate
education
but it's not anything to do with what's
here
all right there's no further discussion
house members in favor of the exceeding
raise your hand senate members in favor
of the motion
2-1 motion passes
i move that we accept the a seed to the
senate position
on the uh lottery division
okay second motion in a second
on the lottery is there any further
discussion seeing none
host members in favor will raise their
hands
senate members senate members in favor
raise your hand
okay uh police standards and training
and
and community colleges no change
and the university system and the
university system is no change
first that our first most the first
motion that we made
take care of these no changes okay
because i was concerned yes that was the
first motion
if there's no changes it's considered
done and i believe lba has made that
okay so um when we see the index
we see the changes that are made and the
first one is house
uh finance section two page one
um
total appropriations amended by the
senate for footnote number two
as you can see the language for the new
hampshire college and university system
for all university system accounts and
community college system accounts
not much of a change i'll make the
motion to a seed
motion to exceed to the change in foot
node two
second an emotion in a second is there
any further discussion
seeing none house members in favor raise
your hands
senate senate members in favor raise
your hand
motion passes okay the next
there's one change down toward the
bottom of the page on department of
energy
the house removed 9u 141
the senate restored it
and we also have the note the following
positions are hereby abolished effective
at the close of business on december
31st
2021 and that's then it goes
after that to all the liquor commission
positions which
were the badged positions which were
eliminated
in the house but not eliminated in the
senate
and also that department of energy
position
um that was in division one
department of energy as they looked at
the positions i'm pretty sure
they were still and i know the
governor's budget directorate told us
that they were still working out the
positions
obviously a change when they got to the
senate which i talked to the governor's
budget director about
before he left for his wedding and he
thought it was an
improvement we have approved and acceded
to
the liquor so i would move to exceed to
the senate in this section
motion in a second to exceed to the
senate any further discussion
seeing none house members in favor raise
your hand
senate members in favor raise your hand
and the motion passes so moving on that
same page uh down to
no footnote number nine department of
information technology
again mr chairman this gets back to the
fact that we knew the senate was going
to have more money we knew
doit had had significant cuts in the
governor's budget we were hoping that
they would be able to restore them and
they worked on that so we will accede to
the senate position
motion and a second to exceed to the
senate position
mr chairman i'm doing that for foot note
9 and footnote 10 as they are the same
very same agency okay
that applies the motion applies to foot
note 9 and 10.
does everybody understand that all right
further discussion seeing none house
members in favor of exceeding raise your
hand
senate members in favor
the motion is adopted moving on to this
page five so if i turn the page i would
have included
footnote 11 in that and now i've turned
the page i would move footnote 11 for
the same reason this is again
doit thank you
okay now we're moving on to a new
right and i just moved it yep and it's
been motion and
i believe i got a second further
discussion seeing none
house members in favor of exceeding
raise your hand
senate members in favor the motion is
adopted
okay now we're moving on because of that
all right footnote 12.
well we changed the way we reduced the
budget we did the back of the budget cut
and the senate did position cuts
it amounted to about the same amount of
well i actually know it spread over
about
maybe a dozen different thing things
uh that we basically put names to the
back of the budget cuts so we
identified the way that was come out and
it came out to just under 60 million
dollars
okay rather than having the back of the
budget cut so
um what foot does that eliminate a
footnote
the footnote has been eliminated so on
page six
the senate has deleted section 12
which is the back of the budget
reduction so if the house is in
agreement they would see to the senate
and there's footnote 13
that's new that's new all right so on
section 12 i would move to exceed to the
senate
second okay foot note 12 move to exceed
to the senate any further discussion
seeing none house members in favor raise
your hands
senate members in favor raise your hand
motion is adopted
all right 13 has no
footnote 13 is a new one from the senate
5 rate increase to skilled nursing
facilities
thank you mr chair this was the guy to
con amendment that we had on the senate
floor the other day
and inadvertently there was a group of
um
facilities that were ex um inadvertently
excluded from the
five percent rate increase that we did
in the budget um
on the senate side so this this includes
those facilities that were
so this adds them in that's a min so
it's good
and again that was the guy to con
amendment
representative berger yes thank you this
is a continuing budget item
in other words it's five percent and it
will go on forever
okay thank you doesn't mean they'll get
five percent every time they get five
percent from this
amendment okay motion from the house to
exceed
motion and a second to exceed for
footnote 13.
okay moving on to the
revenue estimates we can't argue with
these because you've got latest figures
and they look a lot better than what we
had
do we wish to go line by line or we want
i'd recommend the two total lines or at
least okay you want to move that
that we exceed to these uh
revenue estimates uh i i move that we
accede to the
senate estimates for total general funds
and the details above
second okay further discussion
seeing none house members in favor raise
your hands
[Music]
senate members in paper region here
okay
mr kane yes we completed the
actions required on committee of
conference for hb1
sure so the motion right that senator
edwards just made was for the general
fund totals
if you want to approve the education um
on page seven uh highway and fishing
game that would give us
clarity for the surplus statement
purposes
second okay motion in a second for the
additional
for the funds besides just general funds
for education fund fish and game and
highway funds
are included further discussion seeing
none
house members in favor to exceed
raise your hand senate members in favor
of the motion
okay mr chairman representative over
thank you mr chairman senator bradley
and i are
looking working on a couple of things
that may have to be done with the
department of energy
may not have to be done if they are one
might affect
hb1 as i let mr kane know
earlier and one would affect hb2 i just
want to keep you
aware it'll be next week before we work
those out
uh we should perhaps announce now who
the conferees will be on hb2
uh for both sides and the alternates
you have that handy i don't have it with
me
i know i am chairing this is
representative ober i am chairing
the committee of conference on hb2 i
believe representative weiler you are on
a representative umbrella you are on it
representative turcotte who is an
alternate on hb1 is on it
represent packard the alternates are
representative
jess edwards representative
emmerich representative leishman
representative
walner i believe representative irf
and i think that's it represent petrie
are you on that or no he's not
no okay representative major
representative major that's right i was
forgetting one thank you mr king
sure and for the senate uh who they
seated senator moore senator bradley and
senator rosenwald
on house bill 2. first meeting will be
monday morning at 11 o'clock in this
room
and the building will be open to the
public as i understand is that correct
mr speaker and he's shaking his head yes
hallelujah okay have we completed our
action
you have and just for the public what
happens now is that our office will
finalize uh house bill 1 section 1 will
finalize the sections
in the back of house bill one based on
the motions of the committee
and then um there will be a sheet the
committee conference report will be
prepared and provided by ols we will all
need to
we'll all need to sign that prior to 4
p.m on
oh is it 3 p.m on the 17th 3 p.m on the
17th
so all right we'll have it ready prior
to that
mr cain do we have we gotten things from
the print shop for hb2 yet do we know
we did there was a little wrinkle but
we're just going to have to go with it
we'll bring those over and provide those
to the
members on the house bill 2 committee
conference okay so if you're on the
committee conference of house bill 2
please hang around and get your
materials it's
a mere 304 pages or something like that
so
a little light reading for the weekend
so should we go to your office or are
you going to bring them here
we do have the copies here for the
members of the hospital too
we do have it online uh we do on our
website the community conference the
house bill 2 side by side for the
members of the public if you're looking
for that
i should have brought my little room all
right i want to thank the legislative
budget assistant
and the tech people for uh broadcasting
this so that the public could be
involved
i want to thank the senate
and the house members for all their work
on the budget
um it did become a little simpler when
there was a little more money didn't it
yes yes thank you mr chairman and on
behalf of the senate i'd like to extend
my thanks to the
house finance committee for the work
that they have done uh what you gave us
was a was a budget that had a lot of
thought a lot of work put into it
and it certainly made it easier for us
to to complement the work that you had
done so we were able to build upon that
uh we obviously had
more accurate revenue numbers so we were
able to
take the ideas that you were not able to
get in and fulfill
what i believe uh fulfills the needs of
the state
and our local community so thank you to
all for your work
yep this is the most important um
bill to come before the bodies
uh this is our our requirement by
constitution that the
legislature but the house originate the
budget that the senate concur
now it goes on to the governor for a
signature so
and we've also got to go to the house
and the senate bodies and get them to
approve our actions
and i hope they will do so because i
think there's been a lot of thought
go into these things not as obvious in
the time we've spent here but in the
hours and hours that we all spent before
that
um a lot of thought and action and a lot
of discussions with the department so
i hope that is all appreciated by our
other members
and i'm sorry that they're not here but
if they wanted to they could have
watched this so
okay